once you learn the game of money it is
very easy to make money but as easy as
it is to make money it is a hundred
times easier to lose it all if you make
one of these ten mistakes I'll be
talking about today by the way fYI I
have made every single one of these
mistakes I'm talking to you about today
so it's purely comments you from
experience so let's start off with the
first mistake here we go
wasted services let me explain what
wasted services mean what do you become
an entrepreneur and you start making a
little bit of money what starts
happening is all these Massiah
consultants show up and they say if you
hire me my expertise is knowing how to
take your business to the next level how
much because I'm only ten thousand
dollars of consulting you know you need
to paint it and you're just getting
started so you have all this fear that
you don't know what you're doing so
you're kind of like well I'll pay this
guy ten thousand dollars we all have 100
thousand dollars now temperance and your
money is gone then this other person
shows up I know how to create the
website that's going to show you this
$3500
I know how to PR and get you into the
newspaper and the news because if you
pay me $5,000 I know how to be you're
great and next thing you know you just
lost $40,000 we barely got the business
started so you got to keep in mind you
don't want to waste a lot of your money
on these Massiah type of consultants
that show up these two take all your
money from your next legal team let me
explain to why it's so important how to
solve a legal team when I first started
the company and I started my financial
from an October 1 9 from the moment I
started at 5 minutes late I got sued
yeah I got sued five minutes after
started company now when we got sued we
got sued by forming a billion-dollar
company what saved us is we had an
incredible legal team because if I would
have gone constant bullying I want to be
eventually one decayed but if they would
have dragged it out two years later I
would run out of money because these
guys are pretty heavy doing so I got
different types of attorneys I get three
different firm to have general counsel
who handles my structural type of my
business LLC a you don't think C Corp S
Corp how to structure its stock options
you know equity East all this stuff
Aesop's they do it the other one is an
industry when you call it industry
egle attorney that I have you've got a
very expensive the ones that I have
they're 1,200 us and our $800 and up
they're phenomenal
then the other one is marketing so if
you got a sales side if you got a
commission side on making sure that
everything's being done properly that's
the legal side now accounting is another
one I initially when I started I had a
regular accountant to top the big game
but every time I got a hold of me was
never available very annoying very
unprofessional bad attitudes had no clue
what he was doing he lost my paperwork
all the time overpaid all this stuff
finally I said you're fired
I want to got a real accounting firm
that I hired at that time I think was
Jay Cohen and I think I got Cohn Reznick
at that time they did a fantastic job
with their top 50 accounting firm in
America they did phenomenal job but they
saved us so we started doing accounting
everything properly it is very very
important for you to not mistakes with
your legal side with your accounting
side tax wise pay all your taxes early
don't wait a lot of times people get
this $100,000 check or $50,000 check and
you're not getting w-2 so they don't
take your taxes automatically you spend
a fifty as if the fifth is yours instead
of spending the 50s up to 25 is yours
and making sure you take your attachment
you don't take care of that fun you know
how many people are not in business
today simply because they have tax liens
or they didn't pay tax for they lost all
this other stuff that hurt their credit
they lost these things and people aren't
doing nothing business without any more
phone legal papers post attention to
that next hiring resumes versus
believers I made this mistake early I
hired a resume that I brought on board
and all he cared about all we cared
about was the money was going to make
the benefit he was going to get the
American Express card he was going to
get because a former company was working
for he got all that stuff and he was
expected from a start-up and he
pressured me as we dig well you know the
former company gave me this way not a
formal company finally I realized this
guy's not a believer okay this guy was
the money guy all he wanted was to make
sure he's safe he didn't understand the
value of a start-up company so I asked
him this is not going to be a fit he
walked away he's too good for himself
then I brought up a true
liebherr who was part of my board for
five and a half years and eventually I
brought him in because he's no longer
somebody I just coming at as business
he's gonna make a lot of money but he
came in as a true believer so don't just
hire resumes how I believe is next is
residual checks to me expect you what I
mean by this there's this notion that
the cliche of you know one day you're
going to have so much money where these
checks are piling in and they're coming
in it and these money is going to come
in and you can you wrap it you know at
the beach and you're sitting there and
you're you know so great and you don't
work anymore you're home all they don't
sleep wake up at 11 o'clock and you you
know do whatever you want to this is
great this is this is the dream that's
being sold right I don't know if you
realize kids no matter how will they
become they're still your kids if you
choose to have kids you're a parent for
the rest of your life right if you build
a business and you plan on growing the
business it requires attention no matter
how big the business becomes even a
hundred billion dollar company needs
attention and maybe even more attention
but at that time you have some leaders
and board and all that stuff that's
helping you take care to business if you
start living a dream too early very very
early
you're in deep trouble when we started
as a company and I had money in place
and I put it on the business I drove a
GMC Acadia it's what I drove I drove a
GMC Acadia I sold my zo6 drawling Acadia
and we were doing our part and it was
all good and then slowly we didn't have
a house we rented an apartment because
we stayed tight it wasn't about the
lifestyle you see the Lamborghini and
all this other stuff now this is five
six seven years later after having to
put up what we put up with then came to
lifestyle okay Nick will make with
liquid let me say why they quit you'll
see a lot of people who all of a sudden
down the network will go from 0 to 17
million dollars on real estate because
the economy is doing very well and it's
all good so everybody says oh my gosh I
got such a genius she's so great he's so
often he saw this I took over an office
of somebody in Woodland Hills who had in
one point was worth four hundred million
dollars okay there's a net force
from 400 million dollars to 20 million
dollars in two years is what happened to
his network you know why because he was
all real estate and it was a liquid and
he found real estate and mortgage all
this stuff was going to cost to go up
and up and up enough and he was
eventually going to be a
multimillionaire that's fine if someone
you can't go out there and put $100,000
on roulette and say it's going to be
number 22 and if it comes up your
hundred thousand dollars becomes three
point six million dollars there is a 1
in 36 chance that it's going to happen
so if it happens to somebody it's
awesome that happens to a lot of people
have become billionaires because they
were at the right place right time real
estate all the stuff that does happen
but I don't bet my money on exception I
bet my money on predictability factors
let me elaborate every 10 years in the
world or in a country typically in
America some countries is more but ours
is generally 10 years every 10 years a
major crisis happens every 20 years a
massive crisis happens but 10 years a
major crisis happens ok when this crisis
happens let me tell you who benefits
from it you know benefits from is one a
major crisis happens those who are
liquid go sort of liquid you see a lot
of people that say I never have cash I
never had cash a lot of cash I love cash
I don't love cash I was able to survive
it Oh 9 2010 and 11 when no insurance
companies were given contract when
insurance companies were losing money
when AIG almost went out of business
when all this up was happening because
we stay tight and that allowed us to be
able to weather the storm until the good
times came and now we can play little
loose but even now it's cash you know
why because if 2008 was a major mortgage
crisis that happen 2018 we could have
another crisis what kind of crisis
cookie I don't know oil or something
else but you've got to be prepared for
it okay next it's process over value a
lot of times you'll see I was advising
this one attorney was running this law
firm and his law firm spent the same
size for 20 years and it keeps asking me
what United is to make my law firm
bigger men is so crazy and all this
other stuff and then 50 air force
sitting there
10% company he owns 90% of company I am
really doing and then you just see how
finally gets picked up in front can I
talk openly - yes the CFO said look I
want every single month whatever profits
we have you take all of it out of our
account all of it out of yours down and
there's nothing left of the company so
every time I want to invest or advertise
you don't allow me to do because you
took all the profits because that person
was only worried about profits not value
values that this Bank values what's the
value the company and in order to think
about the value of the company you got
to do certain things profits you can
take income all the time there was many
times I could have made a lot more money
and just say give me the proper give me
the proper give me a profit I seek value
more than I do profit but that's the
preference next being too cheap to ship
could be investing not into your people
they not only converts into my people
they're good to go not rewarding your
people not investing into hiring good
quality people I'm not talking resumes
I'm talking believers that require a lot
more money as well but being too cheap
that converts you makes it unrelated
businesses this is this is like imagine
if Apple buy I don't know give me an
example Apple works to buy a Toys R Us
if Apple buys Toys R Us for what now
Amazon boss and it teamed up with Toys R
Us great in why because it's a
storefront became a great merge Apple
goes and buys beats one would Apple buy
beats won't be links to iTunes links to
music okay somewhat it makes sense
Disney buys maker studios why would
visiting buy maker studios it makes
sense okay you got some of these
companies that are buying certain people
that make sense I made a mistake of
investing into an unrelated business I
bought a clothing line for what waste of
money I lost a couple hundred thousand
dollars and even worse than the money I
lost I lost time I put time into that
thing that was wasted time I couldn't
stand the fact that I did that so
unrelated business zero interest in it
if it will benefit your business somehow
some ways consider it if it doesn't
focus on your business next active
passive investors all these guys are all
you know hungry about getting an
investor I can't wait to get an investor
China guy that comes in to say I'll give
you five million dollars this one guy
that was interested in asking to our
company and as to what connections do
you have nothing I just know that you're
going to make a lot of money and I know
this company is going places and I like
to own a pieces here's five million
ounces why would I even consider your
investment you because you're passive or
you can introduce me to anybody know do
you know any relationships no do you
know any anything no but I'm going to
give you 500 dollars done I don't need
$2,000
I want active investors let me tell you
is what active investors do so imagine
you got two guys giving you money what
is five million dollars one is four
million dollars hypothetically the
active investor is going to introduce
you to somebody that's going to give you
a technology or a product or a
relationship or an executive that's
going to take your business from doing
17 million years all obsessed 43 million
dollars here but it give you 1 million
dollars left but that value he brings
them from his experience from the past
took the value this company to X would
you be interested in that that's the
active versus passive look for active
investors versus passive investors that
won't have nothing to do with your calls
when they ask your questions how many
times you're going to call me how many
times do I have to go to any meetings
how many comes out to do anything great
no problem now some people like passive
some just say give the money or leave me
alone
I want relationships and contact is what
I'm looking for because this is leverage
for me mix diversify them explain to
what I mean by diversify this is a
philosophy that I disagree with and let
me tell what I mean by this a philosophy
that I disagree with there are some
times that new entrepreneurs take advice
from someone that's been off for 42
years in business for instance if Warren
Buffett gives you advice after being
worth 60 billion dollars of what he's
doing today that advice may not relate
to your advice of you being in your year
3 of business let me give you a little
bit more of an idea if a person in place
should say I'm 22 years old I just have
a girlfriend and all of a sudden a 93
year old man or 72 year old man wants to
give me advice on how to raise
great-grandkids I don't even I don't not
even married yet but this is how you
raise great grandkids you know and said
I don't even have a kid yet let alone a
grandkid
right there's a lot of these experts
that will tell you to go diversify and
do fine businesses and do three
businesses when I was a kid with this
one guy that was such a good salesman he
sold me on this I ended up being in this
$49,000 one of the best salesmen either
my discussion sell anything to anybody
anything to anybody because he was a
Salesman he was not a believer all he
cared about was process that's all it
was he would stand outside my doing he
would tell me briefcases soon anything
he could sell you he told you hey he
still makes the same amount of money as
he did 17 years ago because all he
looked at people with was a dollar son
why don't you make 40 bucks off this guy
60 bucks off this got $30 off this guy
diverse refining is choose one industry
give everything to it 5 10 15 20 years
later
once it becomes big then you're worth 43
million dollars or 193 million dollars
or 300 million dollars or 6 million
dollars and you choose to put $500,000
in another business that's related to
your business you can consider that but
not already I'm trying to diversify
everything you having different
investments so these are intended to
Douglas mistakes entrepreneurs make with
their money if there's any other
mistakes that maybe you've made comment
on the bottom aside from that our goal
is to give 2 million subs this year 2017
by the end of you by the way a lot of
people are asking the same pattern what
are we doing the next contest for
private mentoring session when value
Timmy gets to 250,000 subs if the next
contest will announce the flying and you
know people from all over the rule will
come in for the next one what we got to
get to quarter million stuff that's the
next goal and then your goal is to get 2
million subs if you haven't stuff click
on the subscribe button here and make
sure you join the notifications while
the notification squad is getting so big
to the point where how do you notice the
notification squad videos come off you
guys are first let me take out a
notification squad you're amazing
you do a lot of great into evaluating
your moment
getting you comment first and you watch
the video so do that if you haven't done
it and if you have any questions
comments thoughts about this video or if
you have any other peers that need to
hear some of this conference as well
share this video with them with that
being said thanks for watching everybody
take care buh-bye
[Music]